Kwezi Qika is one of the best longboard surfers
in the world.
In fact, he could almost be number one - if
you take his story into account.
Kwezi learned to surf in the turbulent Atlantic
Ocean - even before he could swim.
„I really wanted to try the sport for a
long time but obviously I couldn’t swim,
so I had to prolong my time of surfing.
It was very, very scary when I eventually
overcame the fear of not knowing how to swim
and stepping up and going in the water and
being in the water
where I can't swim. But I was so dedicated that I looked past that."
Longboard surfing is often seen as more "artistic
and graceful" than the shortboard version.
As a young boy Kwezi used to sit on the beach
and watch the surfers.
Back then surfing was seen as more of a "white
person's" domain.
But that didn't stop Kwezi.
Nor did his lack of experience in the water:
“I sat on the beach watching them and I
was so fascinated by these nice turns they
were doing and they would come out and talk
about how nice turns they had and I felt so
out.
So then I told them listen I actually want
to try and he said really and gave me my first
board and suit and showed me the basics on
the beach and I was hooked.”
That was when Kwezi was 9 years old.
Ever since then he and his surfboard have
been inseparable.
He actually surfed for three years before
he even learned to swim - all he had to depend
on to save him out in the water was his board.
But it wasn’t just any old board…
“I was lucky, my mom actually bought me
a board which cost her, I think, close to
800 Rand but she managed to get that for me
and that board was my life.”
That was a lot of money in the poverty-stricken
Ocean View Township back then.
But it was money well-invested.
Gang crime is rife there and many of Kwezi's
old friends spent time in jail.
“It was a good thing because it kept him
busy all the time.
Away from the streets and from the bad things.”
Kwezi has become a popular trainer for affluent
would-be surfers along Cape Town’s beaches.
He also has sponsoring contracts.
But his heart is with Ocean View, and the
kids there who attend his free lessons:
“Go to school, surf, cause basically when
you surf you get yourself tired you know.
Just go out there and it’s just you and
the ocean, you understand, nothing, nothing
is stopping you there.
That’s when you are free you know, it’s
like your office and I think that was my call.
Actually even if you’re staying in the hood
doesn’t mean your dreams are crushed you
know, there’s still potential, anything
is possible, you just got to have a vision”
“To be like Kwezi, to stay out of trouble
and do stuff of your own and go on with your life.
Don’t do wrong stuff…”
That is Kwezi’s most important message to
young people.
With donated boards and wetsuits, Kwezi takes
the kids down the same path that he once took
on his way to becoming one of Africa’s first
world-class surfers.